- My first guest went through
their share of setbacks
to become one of the
biggest country acts today.
They have three Grammys, an
Academy of Country Music Awards,
and even a daytime Emmy, because why not?
Their latest album is called Nightfall.
It's amazing, you should get it.
Give it up for Little Big Town y'all.
(applause)
- [Kelly] Hello!
Oh my gosh I'm so bummed that
y'all can't be here in person.
This sucks, but it's so
great to see all of you.
- Good to see you.
- So did you guys hear the family harmony
that just happened on the show?
- Oh, wow.
- [Kelly] I know.
- That was phenomenal.
- Their voices.
And all those parts that they were,
it's so cool.
- I know that low end,
especially when they went down for bones,
I was like, I felt it in my bones.
It was so good.
So how long were you quarantined
from each other this year?
(laughing)
He laughs.
- Like.
- I don't know.
- Several months.
- Several months, and
it's like the longest
that we've ever been
apart from each other.
So yeah, it was very emotional
when we got back together.
- Kinda like old married people,
we really grew to look like each other
and we had never, ever
been apart for more than,
you know, a long weekend.
- Oh man, I know that that's
been the hardest thing is just,
I think as creative people too,
we love to be inspired by
people and around people.
It's a very hard thing, but Kimberly,
you have a personal
project coming out, right?
- I do.
I wrote a children's book about
our family's adoption story
on our little Dolly, and it
comes out this holiday season.
I'm so excited.
- Oh, that's such an
awesome thing because,
especially, we're talking
about representation
and inclusion of everyone.
There's a lot of stories out there,
and they don't really
get to hear their story.
And that's a really cool thing for kids
that are adopted as well.
And like, and if you've
adopted a kid, that's a,
that's a beautiful project.
That was a great idea, and
it's why I brought it up.
- Thank you.
It's called a Dolly for Christmas,
and it's just a story about hope,
whether you have an adopted child or not.
It's just about hope and
never giving up on a dream.
My little Daisy prayed
for a baby for five years.
And finally she prayed,
and she asked Santa Claus for one
and right at Christmas time,
we got our little Dolly.
- Oh my God, that's so--
- Y'all got me crying over here.
- And Philip's crying.
(laughing)
- It's so great.
So wait, Jimmy, you all did some
online challenges in lock down,
so what is the hashtag
basketball beer challenge
and who did it?
(laughing)
- That we had seen that
online so many times.
And then we thought we
would take it on ourselves
to kind of go along with our
new song, Wine, Beer, Whiskey,
and up the basketball
challenge a little bit
'cause most of the time it was beer.
And so I did a beer, a canned wine,
our canned wine and a bottle of Crown.
That was the one that I thought,
okay, I may lose a tooth.
- Oh my God.
So Kimberly, did you try this challenge?
- I mean, I was making
some biscuits that day.
I didn't try the challenge.
- I love you so,
you were making biscuits.
Well Philip, how did your challenge go?
- Man, that is harder to do than it looks.
And one take, my sweet
wife was filming me,
and the beer went flying and
hit her right in the stomach.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Kimberly] That's terrible.
- Well, Karen, did you do it?
- Well, I'm super competitive,
and I could probably continue
to do this all night long,
like tonight after we finish this,
but it didn't go well for me,
and I pride myself in being
fairly athletic and coordinated,
but, and then into the pool,
- [Kelly] And then into the pool.
Well Philip, last time you were here,
you had a song called Over
Drinking, which I love.
I'm sensing a theme, y'all.
- Hey, and you know, we
love all the alcohol.
Wine, beer, whiskey.
- You're just being inclusive.
- [Philip] That's right,
trying to include everyone.
That song, particularly,
was really fun to write
because we were out on the road,
and we were writing with Tofer
Brown and Sean McConnell,
two great writers,
and we had finished a song in the morning
that was really, like,
emotional and powerful.
And then I was like, man,
we need a, we need a break.
We got some wine, we got
some beers and some whiskey,
what do you guys want?
And that's, and Tofer went off,
and we started and then we
wrote this song in like an hour.
It was so much fun.
- It's such a great song,
and it's such a, it's one of
those songs that like I heard,
and I was like, how has
this not been done before?
Like, I was like,
like this is such a great idea,
and it's so clever and
it's such a sing along.
And it's one of those that, you know,
when we're allowed to go to shows
and our lives don't suck,
this is the one everybody
will want you to sing
and sing along to.
It's just so fun.
So I mean, Kim, like
last time you were also
about to play at Carnegie
Hall and the Apollo
for the first time, so how
did that go for everyone?
- That was something
you don't even dream up.
It was bigger and better
than we could have ever, ever dreamed.
Yeah, we started our
tour at Carnegie Hall,
and then we followed it with
two shows at the Apollo,
and we thought 2020 was
just like the best year ever
because it had started out so amazing.
And then we had a little hiccup,
but we'll be back at
it as quick as we can,
but that start was phenomenal.
There's nothing that will ever beat that.
- It was magical.
- Oh man, yeah, it looked magical.
Well, Karen, I know that you love clothes.
So you can add stylist
though to your resume, right?
- I mean, I'm the backup
stylist, you know?
- You're great at clothes.
- There is like dressing, you know,
Ken and Barbie dolls every year or so.
But yeah, I love to do it,
and I had to do some of the press tour,
which ended up being
like, you know, Kelly,
like so many outfits and
so many changes of clothes,
and that's before COVID, so I would,
we would finish like doing
something, a TV performance,
and I would run to Bergdorfs.
- Just terrible.
She hates that.
- Terrible.
Yeah so, but we also,
we've made some big fashion mistakes.
I don't know if you ever have,
but back in the early days--
- Oh my gosh, are you kidding?
I'm like how they wore it wrong, you know,
before my stylist got ahold of me.
Well, we actually, wait, speaking of this,
we have a couple of those
early red carpet photos,
and I thought we could
just take a look at some
and you can tell us about them.
Here's one, so what do you remember?
- Oh my stars.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my stars.
- That is terrible, terrible.
- [Kelly] If terrible is awesome.
- I mean, Johnny, your resident called,
he wants his hair back.
- [kelly] No, keep it, keep it.
So wait, and then there's this,
what do you think of this one?
I love this.
- The one thing that I want
back from those days are my abs.
- [Kelly] Oh Lord, if there is anything
I did not appreciate more in
my twenties, it was my body.
It is just, wow, downhill.
Just you 20-year-olds
hear this loud and clear,
it's over.
It's like, just, you think
you're fat right now.
You're not, wait, you will be.
And then you'll be like, damn.
Anyway, but, so, Kimberly,
so on the new song,
someone told me that you
guys used mouth trumpets
on this song, and I can actually hear it,
especially at the end,
one of the last ones.
So care to explain how that happened
and was wine, beer, or whiskey involved?
(laughing)
- Absolutely.
(mouth trumpet noise)
- Oh yes.
- I think Jimmy has
the best mouth trumpet.
(mouth trumpet noise)
- [Kelly] Oh, I can't do that.
Did y'all all do it?
- Yeah.
- Yes, some trumpets
are better than others.
- We considered leaving it like that.
- You can hear the mouth
trumpet at the end though.
At the very end, that's the best part,
and it's like, I want to go to that party,
where at the end, I feel
like I'm so awesome,
I can play a trumpet with my mouth.
- Well, we were going to
keep the mouth trumpets,
but we decided to add
Jacob from the Brummies,
a great little band,
and he played trumpet on the record.
So we were like, we gotta have both.
- I love it. The vibe is so cool guys.
Like how the song starts out.
It's like, where is this going?
Like, and then how it ends.
It literally is so cool.
That's what I love about you,
you're so adventurous and you
play with different genres,
and it's just really,
it's really, really cool
to be a fan of you
and how y'all are unafraid of that.
And it's nice to go on
the ride with y'all.